The Joe Rogan experience.
The vendors are out three hours long.
It's theirs.
I stayed awake.
I haven't seen it yet.
I heard it's great.
Good enough to keep me awake.
That's,
that's uh,
at saying something from the,
I go to sleep off with time from the heart transplant.
Or You sleep here now?
No.
I went to sleep all the time before the orange.
No,
I get comfortable.
Fuck.
And he's over me.
Yeah.
Well that's zero.
That's the thing too with people train a little body fucking with me.
Yeah.
They train a lot though.
You're always ready to take a nap.
Yeah.
Cause your body's always recovering.
I'm out,
man.
No problem.
Or overtraining is bullshit trainings.
Bullshit.
Oh,
I know you don't.
I think I picked you think that it's not bullshit and overtraining is very real,
don't you?
Yes,
I do.
Yes.
I know who you would say that.
You know what?
Robbed on my Losa says,
uh,
no.
I have no ideas.
When you're overtraining,
your literally,
your muscles start breaking down to pollute your kidneys.
People die from it.
Wow.
That's a big ass long words.
And if you look in the dictionary,
it'll say boasts,
no dry pick beers under resting under recuperation.
That's true.
But a overtraining.
Now if you get enough rest and enough recuperation,
I think overtraining is right.
But if you have to work out hard and then you have to work out again the next
day and you work out hard the next day,
that's a,
that's rubbed on my losis piss.
When you get robbed,
doe you pissed?
Comes out looking like iced tea.
Yeah.
I don't mean the rapper.
[inaudible]
more than a rapper though.
Right?
It's hard to say.
He's a rapper.
Actor.
Yeah.
He's a cool dude.
I mean he had body count,
so that's a metal band.
So he that too.
Yeah.
Right.
Cool.
Um,
but yeah,
it looks like diet coke piss looks like it's fucked up.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
that's what happens in that train.
Every,
I've worked fucking eight hours a day,
eight,
10,
12 hours a day at the post office.
Went to the gym,
put it in another four to six hours for fucking 25 years.
And My piss never looked like,
yeah.
I think that's more endurance athletes and uh,
particularly crossfit.
Lot of crossfit people get robbed.
Oh yeah.
There's a competing gets other people and they get real wrapped up in it.
And I got to ask Jason,
can we put out this good friend of mine?
See if he's pissed.
If it looks like root beer.
It's a real,
real issue for crossfitters and like ultra endurance athletes.
Yeah.
He's one of the top crossfitters kind of,
yeah.
He's like world champion.
Two or three times.
Guys are ridiculously Rediculus Lee fit and him in the,
in my gym and I put them through my training.
He was one of the,
he did this shit like 11.
Yeah.
He's fucking act,
gag,
cross fit.
Neat and [inaudible] kind of laugh at crossfit or something like,
ah,
that's,
you know,
you know girly shit man.
It's boiled.
Crossfit is bullshit,
but that motherfucker is in extremely good shape.
Yeah.
Crossfitting is definitely not,
definitely not bullshit.
No.
It's very hard.
Yep.
What those guys do is very,
very,
very hard.
Yeah.
The real question is whether or not it's good for your body.
And that's where,
um,
that's where I'm not qualified to judge,
but there's a lot of people that are professional strength and conditioning
coaches to frown upon it because they think that those kinds of movements like
power lifting movements like clean press,
that kind of shit.
Yeah.
That should not be done for the maximum amount of repetitions.
I think that should be done for power then you should,
you know,
you should holy stop your maximum or 85% of your maximum for x amount of times
and that's it.
But what they're trying to do is just,
you know,
if Mike does 10 I want to do 12 Mike does 12 I want to do 15 you know,
and they,
they think that there's like Steve Maxwell who's a pretty famous strength
conditioning coach,
he frowns upon it and he just thinks it's just,
those movements are not designed for endurance.
Those movements are designed for power.
He thinks ultimately it's detrimental for your body and that if you want to have
a long career in fitness and constantly be able to work out like deep into your
50s and 60s he just thinks it's very detrimental for your body.
Again,
I'm not the guy to tell that's true or not true and me either.
I'm sure a lot of these,
I need to get one of those top level crossfit guys.
I know I've gone back and forth with rich Froning is that see online,
but I'd never got him on.
Oh yeah,
we'll reach out to him again.
I'm sure Jason would die to be on here,
but um,
he is exceptionally fit.
Ain't no,
they're longterm.
I don't know,
cause he's still a pretty young guy.